よろしくお願いします
今日の話のテーマは まあ結構
現代的な思考を持っている人から作ってもらったもので
皆様に一応内容はそういうわけでわかりやすいと思います
それは注目です いわゆるブッダ的
ブッダ的というか お釈迦様がおっしゃる刹那主義って何でしょうかと
で 現代人々を考えている皆様ではないんだけど
一部の人々は考えている
この現代的な刹那主義とは違うということなんですね
それを現代の社会でそうやって
明日はないんだと 今日だけを楽しもうというふうな感じの刹那主義あるんだということを
私はもうもう最近聞いた話で
まあとにかく話をできるだけわかりやすくしようと思って
経典からいろいろ資料をわざと持ってこなかったんです
で 持ってきたならば 少々難しくなる可能性ありますから
ごく一般的にお話しさせていただきます
で あの ちょっと思い浮かぶストーリーがものエピソード
物語がありまして それはこの
おそらくイソップ物語もあると思います
インドの世界でもいくつか物語として入ってあって
仏教の逸話の中にも入ってあって
おそらく日本でもあると思います
うん ある人がこの貧しい人が疲れて
ある木の下で寝ていたんですね
で 寝ていると 一旦疲れもなくなって
目を開けてみたら この木でいっぱい実が乗っているんです
それで彼が考えるんですね
私はこれ取ってみれば
うーん まあ結構売り物になるんだと
売れるんだと まあその人のまあ
まあ一応それ売っていくらか金は儲かりますと
それでまた来年も またこの木の実を売っていくらかお金儲けて貯金しておけば
いくらか この鶏一羽二羽ぐらい買えるんだと
それで鶏を買って育てれば卵いっぱい産みますから
卵を売るんだと 卵を売ったりして
また鶏を簡単に繁殖できますからね
いっぱい鶏を作るんだと
買っちゃうんだと 買っても大きなスケールで鶏の商売をやるんだと
そうやっていると結構金は儲かりますよと
それだったらまあ鶏どころかじゃなくて
牛も買えるんだと 牛を買ったらもっと金が儲かるんだと
で そうするともう田んぼぐらいでも買って
まあそういう農業でもやらせることできるんだと
そうすると結構お金が儲かるんだから
まあこんな小さなハットみたいな家ではなくてね
まあ結構立派な家でも作られるんだと
家作ったというと やっぱりお嫁さんが欲しいでしょうね
だったらすごい美人のお嫁さんをもらうんだと
お嫁さんもらおうと言ったら
まあやっぱり立派な結婚式を挙げなく挙げないとね
それでまあ友達も呼んで
大げさに行列で馬車に乗って
あの お嫁さんを家まで連れてくるんだと
といえば 馬車が通るといったら
今人が歩くぐらいの道路がないし
やっぱり道路を作っておかないと
道路を作るんだったらこの木は邪魔ですね
さっさとこの木をやっぱり倒しておこうと言って
斧を持ってきて木を倒してしまっちゃったんです
で それで嫁は全部悪いです
で その似てるストーリーは日本でもあると思います
そのストーリーっていうのは一般的なことで
伊勢物語もあります 源氏物語もありまして
源氏物語よりは この一人のお坊さんの妄想の話として
また同じほとんど似ているんですね
あるんですね で そのストーリーでこの何言いたがっているんですかというと
この計画立てるのは悪いということではなくて
何かどこかでおかしいんですね
で それであまりにもこの夢の中で計画を立てちゃうと
この時間関係を忘れてしまっちゃうんです
時間関係を忘れてしまって
彼があの自分の妄想のスタート出発点であったあの木をまず倒してしまっちゃったんです
それでも鶏を買うところには行けません
一回の収入も出てこないんですね
そういうことだから 我々の心の中に
そうやって自由に この思考ですか
思考といえばかっこいいんだけど
私は言うのは妄想という言葉なんですね
妄想が働くんですよ 妄想が働くと
この時間の流れがなくなってしまっちゃうんですね
それであり得 いろんなトラブルが起きてしまっちゃうんです
それは大変な問題なんです
そこを説明すると結構難しくて複雑になるかもしれませんだけど
現代我々にもあるいろんなトラブルを考えると
それは妄想から生まれてくるんですね
妄想っていうのは不思議なもので
このあまり時空関係は考えないんですね
だからいろんなトラブルが起こるんです
一人でいろんな どんなものでも考えられるんです
だから 似ている このブッダに出てくるストーリーをまた続けていますけど
どのようなトラブルが起こるかというと
あるおじいさんが出家したんです
だからおじいさんが出家して悟りを開いて
これ大変素晴らしいことだから
自分の妹の息子がいて
で 妹の息子にも あの子にもやっぱり素晴らしい心清らかにする道を教えてあげたいんだと思って出家させちゃうんですね
その息子さんもおじいさんのところですからということで
ものすごい気持ちよく出家するんです
そこで真面目に出家修行していて
ある に雨後というね 雨が降ってる今の時期なんですけどね
3ヶ月は一箇所に泊まって修行するんだからね
それ終わったら信者さんたちが大変高価な服を
布一枚を寄付するんです
衣を作ってくださいと
それであまりにも高価な布だから
この人がやっぱりこれは私は衣を作って着るよりは
おじさんの師匠に 私の師匠にあげた方がよろしいと言っていい気持ちなんですね
先生を大事に思う気持ち
それでせっかくまた歩いて歩いて歩いて
自分の師匠であるこのおじさんのところに行って
挨拶をして 私はこういう布をいただきましたけど
それはおじいさんに寄付しますと
それをもらって衣を作ってくださいと
おじいさんは阿羅漢になっているし
だからあまり余分に物を持っては持たないという仏教の生き方があるんですね
着るものにしたっても
たくさん持ってはいけないんですね
特に出家の場合は  1枚2枚とかね
まあ一応 1着しかワンセットしか持ってはいけないんです
それ 古くなってくるともう一つセットもらえばいいんですね
ワンセットには何枚か入ってますけどね
だから昔はね 服自体もすごい高価なものでありましたし
それでその人が自分に衣ありますから
まあ私には十分ありますので
君はそれで衣を作って着てください
それは君のものだよと言ったら
その人は妄想しちゃうんですね
やっぱりおじいちゃんが私のものをもらいたくないんだと
おそらく嫌われてるんだと
私のことを大事に思ってないんだと
せっかく持ってきたのに
結構ですよって言うんだから
だからおじいさんに大事にしてもらわないと
おじいさんの愛情がなくなっちゃうと
なんで私は出家している必要あるんですかと
だったら還俗した方がいいんだと
還俗しちゃうと私も若いし
なんかこの仕事を見つけて
まあそれどんどん話を続けちゃうんですね
いくらかお金を儲けて
お嫁さんももらうんだと
お嫁さんもらったら当然子供が生まれるんだと
やっぱり子供が生まれたら
やっぱりおじいさんに見せて
長老に見せて祝福してもらわないと
ということで もう子供の方に心がいってしまったんですね
とらわれて そこで奥さんと一緒に子供を赤ちゃんを抱いて
また同じく車が出てきますけどね
車と言っても 馬車か牛車どちらかですけどね
車に乗っておじいさんのところにお寺に来るんだと
来ると 私は男だから 私はやっぱり手綱を持って
馬をね コントロールして持っていくんだ
それで奥さんが後ろに座って
赤ちゃんを抱いて後ろに座っていると
そこで道路はガタガタ道路だからね
もしあの車輪がね 石の上でも行ってしまえば
ガクンとしますね 車が
それでこの女の人だから
やっぱり手が弱いし 赤ちゃん落としちゃうんだと
と その間でこの人怒ってお前なんでしっかり赤ちゃん抱いておかないかと
言って 自分の奥さんを殴っちゃうんですね
それ奥さんを殴っちゃいますけど
その時はこの自分の先生にあれ
何といいますか うちわで空気を送っていたんです
その空気を送っていながら
そんなことを考えていて
そのまま長老の頭を殴ってしまったんです
長老は何のことなく目を閉じて
ずっとこの自分の親戚の子がね
ちゃんとお世話してくるし
だから目を閉じて静かにいたんですね
いて 何のことなく君はね
自分の家内に殴ることをなんで私に殴るんだと
ただそれだけ聞いたんです
聞いたところで あ この人の思考の流れを全部おじいさん読んでいたんだということをバレちゃって
恥ずかしくて逃げてしまったと
で それはあの仏教の出てくるストーリーなんですけど
だからそういうストーリー
なぜいくつか出ているかというと
人間っていうのはこの空想すること
これ英語でデイドリーミングと言うんですね
それは好きなんですね
で 怖いことは 私たちの生き方の中でほとんどやっているのは
このデイドリーミングという空想なんですね
その空想自体が時空関係と離れているんです
だから結局客観的に見るとおかしいんです
病気なんです そこはやめた方がいいんです
あくまでもできるだけ
この時空関係に絞られて
物事を考えるようにした方がいいんです
そうするとおかしいことにはならないんです
余計な喧嘩も 余計な会社のトラブルも
余計な家庭の中のトラブルも起こりません
家庭の中のいろいろトラブルも
もうほとんど見ると この時空関係からずれてしまっちゃって起こるものなんですね
で 例えばまあ結婚したとする
大体男性の方はまあ自分の奥さんが可愛いと綺麗だと思って結婚するんですね
それで頭の中でそのイメージだけ止まっちゃうんですね
それで時空関係から離れて
自分の奥さんのことを考えたりすると
過去のイメージで物事を考えたりする
それでたまたま二 三年
五 六年 七 八年経ったところで
自分の奥さんの方を見たらもうがっかりするんですね
それで頭のイメージに合う他の人の方に心がいっちゃう
なんで私はこの人と結婚したんですか？とかね
面白くないんだと 綺麗でもなんでもないんだと言わないんだけど
心の中で思ったりする
そういうことで家庭の中でトラブルが起きたりするんです
同じ現象が女性の場合もありますね
頭の中で何か王子様のイメージがあって
そういうイメージがしっかりとある場合はほとんど結婚できないんです
ほとんど結婚できなくて
理想がすごい高くて だから現実から離れちゃうんです
たとえ強引に両親にもう脅されて結婚しても
心は他の方にいるんあるんですね
旦那さんに対していつでも不満ばっかり持っていて
そうやって人間っていうのは
この空想の世界で生きていて
時空関係忘れてかなりトラブルを起こしちゃうんです
それでこのただ一つ 我々にその精神的な問題から解決する方法としてあるのは
お釈迦様がおっしゃっていること
時間論なんです お釈迦様は厳密に物事っていうのは
やっぱり時空関係の中で考えて欲しかったんですね
この刹那という言葉 無常という言葉なんです
お釈迦様は刹那という言葉
まあそれほど使ってない
あれはあんまりにも哲学的であんまり刹那という言葉使ってないんです
無常という言葉は一般的で
誰にでもわかりますから
その言葉を使ってるんですね
無常ですよ で 刹那にはパーリ語では金と言うんですけど
無常はニッチャというんですね
よく使ってる経典では使っている言葉はニッチャという言葉
まあカナという言葉はちょっともうあまり使ってない
たまたまあるだけで それはまあ刹那という瞬間という意味で
それはちょっと仏教哲学的な世界で
もうざんざん出てきて
まあ一般的にはまあわかりにくいかもしれません
まあ無常といえばいくらかはわかります
しっかりと物事を無常であると
自分も無常であると わかっておけば
理解しておけば このがっかりすることはなくなっちゃうんです
空想も消えちゃうんです
そういう人は全然トラブルは起こしません
問題を起こすことはないんです
すごい現実主義だから
ですから 無常ですよということは
決して暗い話でもないんですよ
それはもう人間のある大きなトラブルを直すために言ってる事実なんです
物事はずっと変化していくんだと
物事といえば自分もそうなんです
それ一番大事なものはそれなんです
自分もいつでも変化して変化していくんだと
自分も変わっていくんだと
他人も変わっていくんだと
いろんな状況もずっと変わっていくんだと
大体それは事実ですから
大体みんな反対はしません
反対しませんだけど 精神的にはちょっとトラブルがあるんだから
心の中では認めてないんです
それで頑張っちゃうんですよ
この変化するものは変化しないようにしようと
その努力は本当は無駄になるんです
変化するものは変化しないようにしようとする努力は無駄になるんですね
それからまたトラブルが起きちゃうするんですね
例えば 美しさ 若さ 体力というものは自分のことなんですけど
それは消えていくんでしょうに
それはとにかく止まってもらいたい
止まってもらいたいと
永久的に二十歳でいたいと思ってる
あの並みの努力はすべて水の泡で無駄になるんです
そういうことで 余計に自分の体をいじめて
余計に早めるんですね
この老化現象はすごいスピードアップするんです
自然の中で決まっている速さで年を取るのではなくて
かなり速さで 消えてしまうということもあります
ですから それもいろいろ例を言わないとおわかりにならないと思いますけど
まあ一番わかりやすい
理解しやすい例っていうのは
この親子関係なんですね
親は子供は自分のものだと思って執着する
所有物だと思って執着する
でも子供っていうのは生き物だから
やっぱり毎日変化していっちゃうんですね
親が知らないんですね
この子供は大人になっていくんだということは
知らないのは親だけなんです
大体は あれ不思議でしょ？毎日一緒にいるのに
毎日面倒見ているのに
知らないんですね 自分の子はもう成長して大人になっていくんだと
別の人になっていくんだと
毎日 毎日 毎日 ある意味の心の問題なんですね
ある概念が心の中で止まって止まっちゃうんです
それでどうなるかというと
トラブル起こるでしょうね
あまりにも執着すると
この子供が必ずしもこの束縛を破って自由になりたいと
自分の希望通りに生きていきたいという気持ちは作るんですね
家出をするんですね それは自然なんですけど
親にはそこは認められないんです
だけど親反対するんですね
この反対することで 結果としてはやっぱり親子関係が切れてしまっちゃうんです
なんでそういう残念なことが起こるかというと
頭の中で変化するんだということは忘れて
妄想概念で止まってしまっちゃいますからなんです
だから物事は変化するんだ
変わるんだということはとことん理解した方が安全に
楽しく 楽に ほとんど問題トラブルなし生きていられるんです
この私はまたよく言う例っていうのはもうたくさん出しません
だけどいつでも出す例で説明しますけど
で 日本のバブル現象がありましたね
なぜバブル現象でみんなおかしいことをしましたかと
このおかしいことをした人々のほとんどは専門家なんですね
一般の人々よりもやられたのは銀行とかね
金融関係とかね だからそういう経済の世界でいる人々がよく理解していて欲しかったのは
この経済状況っていうのは瞬時に変わるもんだと
ちょっとしたことで変わってしまうんだと
その変わっていくことをすごく気をつけておかないと
まあどうなることかと
もう経験済みですね だからいまだにこの立ち上がらない理由たくさんありますけど
日本国内事情だけでもなくて
いろいろ事情はあるんだけど
一つはやっぱりこの元に戻りたいと思っているんです
元には戻れません 前へ
のように あの数字だけ増える世界には戻れません
ですから そこは理解しないんです
だからどうすればいいかと
全く新しい考え方 練ることはできないんですね
まあですから この物事は常にいつでも変化していくんだということを
大変いい話で 感情的な話ではないんです
正しい話で まあ少々つらいというか
きついというところはあるんです
例えば 自分の奥さんがずっと美人でいるんだと思うのは気持ちいいんですけど
それは嘘であって それによってトラブルが起こるんですね
自分の子はすごくいい子で
ものすごく親切で 優しくて可愛くて
自分の言うことを何でも聞いてくれるんだと思っているのは気持ちはいいことはわかりますけど
それによって大変な落とし穴があるんです
だから冷静でクールで
物事は変化するんだということを
覚えておいた方が いいんじゃないかなと
私は今思い出したのは
自分がすごい小さい頃
ガキ頃 親の機嫌を取ろうと思って
親のところ 母親のところに行って
いろいろしゃべるんですね
お母さんのことすごく好きですよと
大事にしますよと 元気もなんか体の調子でもどうですか？と言うと
母親は何言ったんですか？とお前優しいんですねと
そんなこと言わなかったんです
いい加減にしろと 何か企んでるんではないかと
はっきりその時言ったんですね
お前らはね この小さい時
自分で何もできないんだから
今このなれなれとついてるんだけど
もうちょっと時間経ったら自分勝手で
親はどうでもいいっていう感じで生きてるんだと
そう言われたら 嘘ばっかしで
そんなことはするわけないでしょうと
子供だからそう思ったんだけど
お母さんなしにもう生活できるわけないんだと
思ったんだけど 事実はどうですかというと
別にどうったことなく
もう出て行ったきりで
家には戻らなかったんです
ある一定年齢 やっぱり家を出たいと
と思ったんです めんどくさいんだと
母親言うこと聞かなくちゃいけない
父親は言うこと聞かないしかない
兄弟言うこと聞かなくちゃいけないし
もうやることばっかしで
家を出たいと で だいたい普通の人
家出るよりはかなり早かったんだけど
で 出たっきりで戻らなかったんです
出る時は我々はもうそんな喧嘩して出たわけじゃないんだけどね
母親一つだけ言ったんですね
まあ出てもいいんだけど
あの 出家してから家にもたまたま戻ってこいと
あの自分もあの料理ぐらい作って食べさせたいんだと
当たり前やと その時は思っちゃうんですね
そんなことはって言ったんだけど
一度も母親が作ったご飯を食べたことないんです
出家してから は これ良くないなと思っているんだけど
やっぱり時間もなかったし
家に戻ったってもほとんど 10 分
15 分で帰っちゃったんです
もう一つ言ったんです
月一回でも手紙でも書きなさいと
だから母親は心を決めて
もう家から出そうと思って
そういうことなんですね
はい わかりましたと言ったのはいいんだけど
一回も書いてないんです
ひどいもんなんです 一回も手紙書いたこともなかったんです
それでもって母親が悩んだかというと
まあすごい母親だからね
もう悩んだことはなかったと思いますけど
だから事実はそれなんです
他のものは単なる感情で事実ではないんです
うん 時々みんなもう母親のことをよく心配しているんだ
父親のことを心配して心配してよく悩んでいるんだとかね
言うことは言うんだけど
実際あなたは何をやってるんですかと
何回母親を見るために行ったんですかと
１年に１回 何回ですかと
そこを見たら何もやってないでしょうに
そういうことだから この感情で私はもうずっと忘れることなく母親のことを心配しているんだとか言ったって
大きなお世話で何も役に立ちません
一度も行って顔を見せようとしないんだから
ですから こんなこの感情的なこの生き方すると
我々は時空関係からずれちゃうんです
時空関係からずれちゃうんですね
それでただ一人勝手で
頭の中で偉そうに威張ったりする人もいるし
よく面倒見ているんだとか
あるいはすごく心配している人もいるし
どっちかでも意味がないんです
ですから お釈迦様はこの無常ということを悟るために必要な
理解するべき大変大事な真理なんですけど
一般的な社会にお釈迦様は無常のことを教えて言いたかったのは
より具体的になります
なりましょうと この時空関係っていうのは
物事はその中にあるもんなんですね
永久的なものはないんです
で そこを理解して生きていれば問題ないんだと
でもそう言われると 少々もうどのようにすればいいかとか
何か分からないんですね
その嘘で言うと分かりやすいんだけど
事実を言うとなかなか分かりにくいところがあるんです
簡単にみんな頑張りましょうとかね
掃除機になりましょうとか
一生懸命やりましょうとか
そんな風な話だったら何か分かったような気がするんだけど
結局それは分かったような気がするだけで
何も分かってないんです
かえって時空関係の中で物事はちゃんと瞬間瞬間変化しているんだということをわかって生活するってことはまた難しいんですけど
それでなんでそういうことを言いますかね
それは人間にとってはすごく智慧というものが必要するんですね
無常を理解する人にとっては
必ずも必要なものは智慧なんです
安心することはできなくなっちゃうんです
はい あっ 貯金がこれぐらいあるんだと
じゃあ安心だと じゃあ結婚しちゃった
もう安心だと みんな安心したいでしょ
仕事を見つけて安心しようとする
結婚して安心しようとする
子供を産んで安心しようとする
ちゃんと運動をして スポーツをなさって
それから健康的な食べ物をちゃんと体にいいものを食べて安心しようとするんです
心の中にそれやるんでしょ？この安心ししたいという気持ち
この若い人々にもあるんです
そちらはあまり気づかないんです
なぜならば 若い人は安心だと思っているんです
それだから 例えば若い時は親の教えの教えをいただいている時は
親がいるんだから 何か言えばやってくれるんだという安心感がとっくにあるんです
だから元気で行動しているんだけど
わがままで どんどん大きくなってくると
その安心感が消えちゃうんです
それからずっと探すのは安心感なんですね
安心したいんだと いい仕事を見つけて安心したいんだと
早く結婚して安心したいんだと
親も言うでしょ  女の子たちに
早く結婚して親を安心させなさいと
冗談ですよ あんなこと
それで もし結婚していたならば
早く孫を産んで顔を見せなさいと
何やってるんですか？これ
安心感ないんです だから仏教で結局何をするかというと
とんでもないことをしようとしているんです
この安心感を壊そうとしているんです
安心するなと 無常っていうのはそういうことなんです
だから あんまりこの感情的で美しくて
涙流せるような感動する話じゃないんです
苦しくて涙が出るかもしれませんだけど
安心はなしと でもそれは事実なんです
結婚しても 仏教的な社会ではほとんど離婚はないんです
離婚も最近なんです 離婚現象は我々の国
国でも 私はもう日本に来る前
その間まで もし誰かが離婚したら新聞に出るんです
ニュースとして なんでしょうかね
あれは それぐらい珍しいニュースなんです
別にタレントさん系離婚したっていう話じゃないんです
ごく普通な誰かが そこで向こうは離婚難しいし
まあヨーロッパ的な法律だから
それにはそれなりの裁判があります
ですから この裁判に訴えて
こういうこういうわけで離婚ですよという
それをちゃんと証明してあげないと認めません
ですから その裁判で何を喋ったかと
どういう記録かと 全部裁判レポートまで出て
まあ裁判官はまあ離婚認めましたと
なんであれぐらい珍しいことになったかというと
だから私はこの結婚している人々はちょっとちょっと試して
まあ調べるんじゃなくて
まあただ見ているだけなんです
見ていると みんな毎日大変なんです
安心っていうことはないんです
毎日毎日の勝負なんです
奥様たちも旦那さんたちも
まあたまたまわがまま言って喧嘩したってもいいんじゃないかということじゃないんです
毎日気をつけるんです
その毎日一日に限って生きてるんだから
まあかなり持ちます 私も自分の母親と父親
まあ喧嘩するのは見たんだけど
あれ 喧嘩といったっても
母親が一言葉言う それに父親も一言葉言う
一回で終わるんです ずっと喧嘩ということは見たことはないんです
まあ大体覚えている限りはね
もうそれも昔話だから
もうほとんど覚えてないんだけど
覚えて限りは まあ我々のことで喧嘩したんだけどね
まあ子供はたくさんいましたし
だから母親は大変でしょうし
だから父親は思うほどコントロールできませんし
母親はすごい自由主義でしたからね
コントロールというのは全くしなかったんですね
だから我々はものすごい自由に大きくなりましたけど
で ですから父親は夜家に帰る時に
たまたま我々はすっごく大げさして
大げさ 大騒ぎで もう遊ぶわ喧嘩するわ
もういろいろことを兄弟同士で
父親はなんか仕事をしようと思っちゃって
これなかなかできない
あっち走るは こっち走るはとか
ものすごい大騒ぎしたりすると
それで父親は我々を叱るんじゃなくて
母親叱るんですね 子供たちになんとかしなさいよと
言われたら 母親の私だけかと
私の何といいますか 向こうの言葉ですとすごいきつい言葉なんですけどね
私だけで作った子供かというふうな
何か人を言い返しちゃうんですね
だからあなたにも責任がありますよと
だから父親はすごく怒ってるんです
その場合は で そこでじわかに返すことは
まあわしがなんか言っちゃって
こいつたら死ぬかもしれませんと
何かやったらと ということは
あまりにも激しく悪ガキやっていると
ちょっと体罰でもしてほしいんです
父親から見れば でも自分ではやりませんと
男ですから そこを母親にしてほしい
母親もなんで私だけ子供の面倒見るんですか？と
子供の性格をしっかり正すことには
あなたにも半分責任があるんですよ
と言って もうダメということを言っちゃうんですね
それぐらいでもう会話終わっちゃうんです
会話と言ったっても あれすごい喧嘩みたいでしたけどね
だからこのそれ以上言ってはいけませんと
だってそうではないか
ああではないかと言っちゃうと
ものすごい喧嘩になって
どうなるかわからない
だから不思議なことを父親にしたっても
自分がいきなりカッとなったら次にどうなるかとわからないと
その変化っていうのはなんとなくみんな知っていたんです
だからカッとなった 殺したとか
そういうのはないんです
ですから 変化するんだと
我々の心も今は聖者聖人みたいな心を持ってるんだけど
次には悪人の心にもなることはあり得るんだと
ということを知っておけば
そういうのは条件次第なんだと
周りはみんな良くて 大変行儀良くて
性格が良くて そういうグループの中にいると
誰でもすごい立派に行動する
環境が変わったとする
そうすると周りにいる人々はすごく行儀が悪くて
意地悪で嫌みばっかり言う
グループに行ったとする
そうすると自分がどんな反応するかと
自分でもわからないんですね
だから安心しない方がいいんです
安心するよりは 安心したら
それはものすごい危険なんです
だから仏教の無常の話で我々に言っているメッセージは
安心するなかれということなんです
人生においては 死ぬ瞬間まで
あまり面白くないですね
そう言われると 何か仏教でも修行すれば
何かお経でもあげれば
すごい家庭安心 なんとかなんとかなればその方がありがたいと思うんだけど
あれは嘘なんです お守りでも買ってきて
家にポーンと貼っておけば
あのなんて言いますか
ありますね あの火災にならないようなお守りとか
事故を起こさないようなね
交通安全のお守りとかね
あれは安心したいという人間の切望というか
もう必死な願いなんですね
でもお釈迦様は言うのは安心するなかれと
運転するんだったら ステアリングホイールを捕まってるんだったら
ずっと安心してはいけませんと
慣れたもんだと思ったらもう危ないんですね
そういうことで 仕事にしたっても安心してはいけません
いつどうなるかわからない
裏で何が起きているかわからない
周りで社会で何が起きているかわからない
それには敏感にいなくちゃいけないんです
それだったら安全なんです
安心しないと 安心しないと安全するんです
だから今日はそこら辺は覚えておいてほしいんです
もう結婚してもう十年も経ってるんだから
まあ安心だと思わない方がいいんです
三十六年経っていても安心しない方がいいんです
何が起こるかわからない状態をよくキャッチして
環境の変化もよくキャッチして
一瞬先はわからないんだと
いつでもこの要注意で生きていることが仏教で言ってる生き方なんです
仏教で言っても お釈迦様がおっしゃってる生き方なんです
仏教もたくさんありますから
違う違う生き方も言ってるかもしれませんだけど
なんでそこまで人をいじめるんですかね
お釈迦様は 何か呪文でも教えてもらって
もうこれだけやればすべて解決するんだとかね
そういうふうな神通力でもしてもらった方がよかったのにね
あれ 人をいじめてるわけじゃないんです
人間に必要な一番大事なもの
人間育ててないんです
すべての幸せをもたらしてくれる
たった一つの能力 人間にあるんです
それは全くない ゼロ それは何でしょうかというと
知恵なんですね 知識ではありません
知識っていうのは勉強したものと習ったもの
身について訓練して習ったもの
知恵っていうのは その瞬間瞬間で現れるものなんです
瞬間でパッとひらめいて
あ こうするんだと それは知恵なんです
だから知恵っていうのは
あればあるほどすごい気持ちよくて落ち着いていられるんです
この問題が起きても もうびっくりしない
他人がすごい赤い顔をして
あんたしてまた大変なこと
何ですか？ああ そうですか
じゃあこうすれば？ってすぐ言えるんです
で 今また自分の話を思い出しましたけど
私はこの  自分のお寺でいたことはほとんどなかったし
家出ただけではなくて
お寺も出ていた なんかいつでも家出状態で
で 違うお寺でいて 大学に通ったりしていたんだからね
ある日 田舎の生まれた田舎の
長老が夜なんですね  10時半ぐらいで
あの国は 10時半っていうのはもうほとんどものすごい夜なんです
みんなもう 9時になると
もう電気全部消して もう休み
で 朝早く起きるんだから
だからもうほとんどバス停も何もない
それでも車を借り合わせて自分のお寺に来たんですね
そしたら なんでこんな時間で？とかね
って思ったんだけど 私はその田舎の長老っていうのは
父親みたいに大変尊敬していた長老で
すごい素晴らしい人で
だから来たら まあおそらく何か大変な用事がなければ来ないともして
おそらくこの私が泊まっていたお寺の長老も有名な人で
その長老の何か用事があっただろうと思って
で ちょっとちょっと喋って
私のところ部屋に来て
あの一緒に行きましょうか？と
それ冗談に言うんですね
せっかく田舎から車で来たんだからね
私しかいないし まあ一緒に帰りましょう
一緒に行きましょうと
言うことはあまりにも面白いし
私はちょっとためらうんですね
と言ったっても 別に何かやることもないし
もう明日も何かいろいろ私にある
まあまあそう言わないで
ということで  言ったら車に乗ったんです
それでずっと行く途中で
いろいろ世間の話やらね
いろんなもう周りでいろんな話をするんですね
まあいろいろ人っていうのも
何があったってあまりね
驚かない方がいいんですってとかね
もう何言ってるんですかと
で 考えながらお寺に近づいてくると
訳が言うんですね あんた知っても大変なことになったんだよと
何ですかと とね 自分のおじさんなんですけど
父親の弟なんですけど
毎日お寺に来て お寺のいろいろお手伝いしたり
お寺の面倒を見てあげたりしていたんですね
お寺でちょっとした事故を起こしちゃって亡くなっちゃったんです
で その夜 亡くなったんだとわかって
すぐもう病院に運んで
その勢いで私のところに来たんですね
それで聞いて まあやっぱりそこで長老はどれぐらい心配しているんですかということなんですけど
私のこと で いきなりまあ亡くなったんだよという話を聞いた瞬間で
私の頭に浮かんだのは
まあ予想しなかったことで
そんなに年でもなかったし
まあ別にショックかどうか何もわからないんですね
まあ大変だということは浮かんだ
大変だ 次の瞬間に浮かんだのは
じゃあどうすればいいんですか？っていう
どうすればこの問題は解決するんですか？亡くなったんだから
もう生き返ることもないし
そこでもう何も言わないで
じゃあまあいいわ わかりましたということで
お寺に行って まあどういうことですかと
何が起きたんですかと聞いて
じゃあ その瞬間で年上のお坊さんたちのは行動できなくなっていたんですね
事故だからね これ大変な問題なんです
厳しくて厳しくて まあ調べるは調べるはもう片っ端から
またお寺でしょうし で
それでまあじゃあわかりましたということで
私はそれから全部もうリーダーシップを取って
やるべきことは全部きっちり片っ端からやってしまったんですね
悲しくなることも 驚くことも
がっかりすることも 落ち込むことも何もなく
それでおじいさんの奥さんの問題やら
その子供たちの問題やら
まあお寺に帰ってくる法律的なありったけの問題やら
信者さんもお寺にいろいろ悪口文句言おうとしているし
そういうことやら 全部一つ一つ一つ一つ解決しながらしながら
瞬間 瞬間 瞬間で信者さんたちみんな集めて
まあこれは大変だ こんなことお寺であってはならないとか
事故は事故だから あってはならないと言ったっても
これはちゃんと取り調べしなくちゃいけないんだとかということで
お寺に集めたんです だから
長老も他のお坊さんたちも
もうすごい怖くて どうしようもなくて
行ったら私は先に言って
なんでしょうかと 別に調べることないんですよと
私のおじさんだからね
私はもう知ってるんだから大丈夫ですと
そしたら信者さんのグループの会長があ
あんたそう言うんだったらね
我々も何も言うことはない
じゃあ帰りましょうと
ただ それだけでもうそちら帰ってしまったし
まあ事故があった後 お寺のお坊さん誰もいなかったんで
他の法事に行って 帰るときはそういうことになっていて
ですから その時もそんな地盤試しになって申し訳ないんだけど
大体何かできることあったら伝えてくれる人々はすごい親切だったら
いろいろ溜まって溜まって溜まって
回りで回りで回りで回りで喋るかもしれません
それは喋る人の親切さなんですけど
でも知恵っていうのは
どんな問題でもどんと受け取って
あ そうだったらこうしますと
すぐ答え出すことなんです
で 世の中でどんな問題が起きても
どんな問題が起きても
知恵があって 見てください
答えがあるんです 答えが必ずもあるんです
答えがなければ問題と言いません
それはそれだったら 生きている間では
生きて生まれた時から死ぬまで
問題が起きたら答えがあるならば問題ないでしょうに
それだったら なんか言葉のカラクリみたいな話なんですけど
その問題が起きたら それに答えがある
答えにもいろいろ種類があります
でも 我々見ている世界では
ほとんどの場合は人間が問題にぶつかって
そこで行き詰まり状態になっちゃうんですね
手も足も出ない状態になっちゃうんですね
ものすごいショックを受けちゃうんですね
どうしようもないんだ
どうしようかと  女の人だったらもう泣き崩れて
もう何にもできなくなっちゃう
男の場合は泣き崩れないかもしれませんだけど
全部止まっちゃうんです
体も心も 女の人は止まりません
もう随分泣く 泣いたりいろいろことしますからね
男性の場合は もうそういう解決できないことに出会っちゃったら
いきなり心も体も停止しちゃうんです
動かなくなっちゃうんです
だから それからゆっくり動こうとするんだけど
体だけは 頭は動かないんですね
だからそこは問題なんですね
ですから それは解決できるのは
問題ができたらその瞬間で答えが出て必要
出る必要あるんです その能力出てくるのは
この安心しない人なんですよ
安心しちゃうと答えが出てこないんです
安心しているんだから
まあまだ俗っぽい例に戻りますけど
例えば自分の子供は万引きしないだろうと
自分の子供は人をいじめる
いじめることをしないだろうと
こんな優しい子はするわけじゃないんだと安心してみてください
そういう安心していて
もししたならばどうなるんです？頭狂ってしまっちゃうんです
それでいいんですかと
そういうことだから 安心しない方が幸せなんです
どんなものにしたっても
安心しないでいると智慧が生まれてくるんです
なぜならば いつでもこの状況を判断しながら
状況を研究しながら生活しているんだから
この間 このちょっとした夜なんです
テレビの番組があって
このほんのちょっとしか見ていないんだから
全部前後関係何もわかりませんだけど
この見たところだけ私は覚えているし
で この現代のね 仕事状況とかね
で もうリストラになったりするんだと
たくさんの人々がクビにもなったりするんだと
それである人が言うのは
まあそういう人々はいらんと
でもう一人タレントさんがいて
なんだとと言って もう立ち上がったりして
まあ冗談で立ち上がったりしたんだけど
いえ いりませんと だからあんたいうのは
このまあ 今までずっとこのあの
戦争終わってからね もう随分真面目に頑張って頑張って仕事をして
こういう社会作った人々が
もう今 真面目に頑張っている人々は今いらないと言っていることですか？と
そうです いりません 無駄だと
だから考えてもすごい失礼な言い方なんですね
もう歳 歳になっている人々はもう一人もいりませんと
みんな出て行けと 今必要なのは違う人間だと
今の社会は違っているんだから
そういうことで 残酷に人々をもうリストラになったり
クビになったりはしますね
我々はそれはいけない
いけないと思ってますけど
じゃあ その問題でも仏教の目から見ると
なぜ 年間も会社に尽くした人が
平気でリストラにされちゃう
その人が安心しているんです
毎日毎日同じ仕事をやって
だから経済状況は安定していたんだから
品物を作れば売れるし
まあそれで安心して 自分がこのマンネリでワンパターンでずっと仕事をし続ければ
まあ大丈夫やと まあ私はもうまあこれぐらい仕事をしていたんだから
まあ上上行くのは当たり前で
給料上がるのも当たり前で
そこでちゃんと退職金もらって退職するのは当たり前だと
どうなるかというと 社会が変わっていくんです
この紙の上でずっと計算しながら
電卓を持って計算して
もう何週間もかけてもうちゃんと何か作ったとする
今はそうじゃなくて もうほとんど 1時間以内でコンピューターでササササ作って印刷までしてくれる
昔だったらそこはちょっと間違いだなと見つかったら
またテストして産業して
また直すと また計算し直しと
今はそうじゃなくて ここら辺ちょっと間違ってる
あ そう じゃあはい 直りますと
瞬時に直してまたプリントするんですね
今状況変わったんですね
売れる品物も変わったんですね
昔売れた品物は今は売れません
そこでこの安心した人々はみんなこのデッドウェイトという
何と言いますかね 役に立たない
ただ重さだけの人間になってしまうんですよ
だから仏教は人間にこのデッドウェイトにならないように
デッドウェイトって日本語でなんて言えばいいんでしょうかね
負担だけ 負担だけの人間にならないようにしてくれるんです
例えば会社で年も仕事をしたっても
安心感さえなければ その場でその場の現状に合うように自分を調整できるんです
この新しい能力は今更身につくことできませんと
初めからもう決めつけちゃうんです
それは良くないと私は思います
例えば年取った人が今更もうコンピューターでいじったり
仕事をするのもできませんと
と言ったら 仕事はないんだからもうリストラになっちゃうんですね
なんで逆に思わないんですかね
ガキにできるんだったら
なんで私にできないかと
仕事もろくにわからないし
会社に入ったばっかしで
なんだ このガキにできるんだったら
私にできないかと 言って込めて教えてくれればどうですかね
君はこれ知ってるでしょ
教えてちょうだいと 言えばなんとなくうまくいくんです
また自分の例になりますけど
申し訳ないんだけど 私は出家した
この大長老 お寺の長老はものすごい大長老で
国でものすごい大変な有名な人でした
他のお坊さんたちは 我々は私の長老のところに来ると
すごい気をつけて気をつけて
もう想像できないほどのものすごい人物ですから
だから当時の総理大臣でも政治家でも
お寺に来るんです 会いたい場合は
ある人がこの これ 大学の教授でしたけど
この高校 アーキオロジカルデパートメントという
この考古学的にこの物事を保存するこの省がありまして
そこでこの館長になりたくて
あの私の長老からもし推薦状ですか
あの何かもらったら 自分が願書を出すときは自分が通るだろうと思ってお寺に来たんです
そして私は長老いなかったんです
この人 長老帰るまで日待っていたんです
私は考えるのは こんなすごい偉い人がなんでそんなもう他の人で来てもいいし
あるいはまあ用件だけ言っておけば
長老手紙ぐらい書いてあげるんだから
ほとんど書くのは私でしたし
だからまあ手紙でも送られるんだと思っていたんだけど
もう一日中苦労して帰るまで待っていて
料金を置いて手紙を書いてもらって帰っちゃったんですけどね
まあ当然その仕事をもらったんだけど
その人は だからそれぐらい偉い人だから
もうものすごいみんなこの気をつけるというか
緊張するというか その長老が私がもうもうガキで
その時ももう学校に行って勉強したりする
私は現代的な知識 その長老はもう １９世紀で生まれたんだから
２０世紀ではないんです
１９世紀で生まれて はっきり日にちを覚えていないんだけど ７
歳で出家してたんだそうです
すごい子供の時 だから世の中のことは知りません
結局は それで私が現代的ないろいろ学校に行って勉強したりすると
何のことなく私にお前らはね
いろいろ新しいことを勉強するでしょ
だからそういうのは私にも教えてくれよ
って言うんです だから教えてくれと言ったら
もうこちらもすごく長老にそう言われると
すごく気持ちなんかすごくこの
まあ年は随分離れていたんだからね
やっぱり可愛がってもらえるのはすごくありがたいんですね
それで自分が勉強するものやら
いろんなことやら まあさんざん長老にこういうふうなことを勉強しましたとか
こういうこういうことですよと
これはこうこうですよとかね
いろんなことを言う また
仏教の話も長老から質問したりする
長老もなかなかのものでしたからね
どんな質問出したってすぐ答えたし
そこで時々聞こえ 私の説法をすると
我々も聞いていたんだからね
私から聞いた話 この現代的な知識やら情報やら
そういうものは何のことなく
このガキから教えてもらったものを言ったら恥ずかしいとか
そんなこと何もなく 説法するとき
みんなの前でしゃべる時とかも使うんです
余計なプライドとかね
あれぐらいの人がね 何もなかったんです
だから あれはやっぱりまあ
あの長老が仏教しか 仏教の世界のことしか知らなかったんだから
やっぱりもうプライドとかそういうもの何もなく
この変化しつつ この世界でいかに自分も変化しながら生きていなくてはいけないかと
それはわかっているんです
だから相手は弁護士であろうか
医者であろうか どんな専門家のの人であろうか
教授であろうか も教えてもらうんです
それで最終的には私が入って勉強した大学のこのカウンシルという一番偉いグループがいるんです
大学の科目やら全て決める
このなんとかカウンシル
向こうのことはセネというんだけど
そのカウンシルのメンバーになったんです
ということは 学生としてはもう顔を合わせることもできないぐらいの位
いるんです いるんだけど
寺にそのままだったら
お前らは何を勉強してるんですか？とか
何のことなく聞いて そういうものは長老知らないことだったら
ああ そうですか それでそれで覚えておくんですね
だから会社の場合も まあ自分が 20年仕事してるんだからといって
今年入った人からなぜ教えてもらうのは悪いんですかね？どこにそれかっこつけないってことあるんですかね
そこは不幸な道だと だから物事は常に変化してあって
その世界で偉い人も偉くない人もないんです
結局落ちこぼれになっちゃうんです
いくら偉い人であろうか
毎日心を回転させて新しく新しくしないと終わりがないんです
落ちこぼれになってしまっちゃうんです
台風に流され 流された
なんかゴミのような感じになってしまっちゃうんです
そういうわけで この仏教でいう
この物事は瞬間だけですよということは
ものすごく人間に大変な知恵を開発してくれる
人間はいつでもこの磨いた刃物のような感じ
いつでも切れるようなシャープな状態に置いておくんです
で 我々の社会を見ると
このちょっと 5年年の差があるとさっぱりわからなくなっちゃうんですね
この間 テレビでまだ番組を放送してないと思いますけど
NHK でこの流行語の調査なんとか放送するんだという番組の宣伝だけ
コマーシャルだけ見たんだけど
このボディピアスとかね
おじいさんたちに普通のサラリーマンたちに聞くので
知ってますか？と 知りませんと
もう言葉のリストを作って
今流行ってる言葉ですよと
全然知りません 世の中で知らないものはいっぱいあるもんだなとかね
聞いてあの一覧表見たら私は全部知ってるんです
私にとっては全く関係ない世界なんですけど
この流行語という言葉は
私はだいたい知らないといえば
これあまりにも残酷に
変に日本語をむちゃくちゃ変曲されて使う言葉とかありますから
まあそういうのはもうちょっとどういう意味かと
聞いてみないとわからないんだけど
今はなんとかもうちょっともう今古くなってるんだけど
だっちゅーのって言葉あるでしょ
私はその言葉の意味だけじゃなくて
どんな気持ちで どんな感情で何を表すためにそれ使ってるか
自分は使いませんだけど
それ初めてテレビで放送した時
なんて気持ち悪い言葉かとと思ったんで
正直なところ 何かもう自分が人気者になりたくて
わざわざと強引に日本語をおかしくするだけではないかと
もうちょっと頭使えという気持ちはあったこと
確かにじじいだからね
あったんだけど まあ結局若者の間でそれ流行ってしまって
まあそれなりの言葉になったところで
あ こういう気持ちで こういう風に
このように使いますよと
だからやっぱりこの物事は日本語であろうか
経済状況であろうか 我々の生き方
体そのものであろうか
もうずっと回転して変化していくんですね
だから過去を捕まって過去を握って
絶対もう私は変えませんよというと
もうバカもいいところなんです
だから これ 人間の心の一つの病気なんだ
いつでも過去に束縛されて
過去をぎゅっと握って
過去で生きているんですね
だから死体なんです それもお釈迦様の言葉なんです
死人だと なぜならば過去死んでるんだから
過去のことで もう何あろうか
もう過去のことに 私は今までそんなことやったことはないんだと言うでしょうに
悪いことだったら君はわかります
悪いこと今までやったことはない
だからこれからもやりませんというのはわかりますけど
いいことなんてそんなことやったことはないんだと
だからやらないということでしょうに
もう未来はないんですね
そう言われると だからこの過去を握ってはいけません
それはもう大変な不幸な道になる
死人だからどうせいらんものなんですね
この前のこの同じ講演会で私は言ったストーリーがありますね
あるお母さんが 末すじ家庭のお母さんがお嫁に行って
そこで一応幸せになって
一人息子が生まれてくる
息子が生まれたら もう奥さんとして立場が安定したんですね
そこで安心もしたでしょう
もう安心やと 家の奥さんとしても認められるんだと
なぜならば 息子を産んだんだから
安心していたんだけど
遊んでいると歳で子供が死んじゃう
死んじゃったら そのお母さんがもう認めたくない
これは で 頭がおかしくなっちゃって
あの子供 私の子供は死んでない
ただ寝てるだけですよと言って起こそうとしている
みんなもう起こそうとして
もうもうダメやと もう死んでるんだと
葬式やりましょうと でも聞かない
ものすごい凶暴で 何言うんですかと
私の息子は死んでない
寝てるだけですよと あんた方は頭悪くて薬も治療もできないだけではないかと
私は何とかして子供を治してやりますというと
あの遺体を抱いて あの斎場ですか
川渡から歩き回ったんですね
いいお医者さんがいるんですかと
みんな追い出すんですね
薬はないんだと そこでやがて
まあ 1 日中歩くんだからね
まあ仏教の信者さんたちがもうわかって
この人はまあちょっとしょっぺ
現実を見たくない かわいそうやと
じゃあお釈迦様に会うようにしましょうと言って
まあまあ あの お姉ちゃん
あのいいお医者さんがいますよと
これぐらいの病気だったら何のこともないんだと
まあすぐ治してくれますよ
何のこともないんだと
行ってみなさいと 行ったらお寺に行く道を教えてあげたんですね
それで彼女はまあ お釈迦様のところに行って
お釈迦様にお釈迦様はお医者さんだと思っているんですね
どうにかして私の子供を治してくださいと
そうしたら お釈迦様は何をおっしゃったんですかと
お釈迦様はまあはい わかりました
うん 治ります 治せます
でもあんた ちょっと薬持ってこいと
何でも持ってきますよと言ったら
じゃあだったら こんなちょっとマスターの種を一握りぐらい持ってきてくださいと
なぜマスタードになったかというと
インドの料理は毎日使うもので
どこにでもあるもので
どんな家にもあります
そこで売り物でもない
もうもういっぱいありますから
ああ それぐらいだったらもういくらでも持って
んだと それたくさん要りません
ほんのこれ一握りぐらい
でも一つ条件がありますと
その家で その家系で人が死んじゃったら
そのマスタードはダメですよと
はい わかりました すぐ見つかってきますということで
また片っ端から歩き回るんです
だからどんな家に行っても
まあマスタードちょっとくれませんかと
まあいいですよね じゃあいくらでも持っていってくださいと言ったら
この家で人が死んだことがありますかと
あんた何言うんですかと
一人二人のところじゃないんだと
次の日はじゃあこのマスタード要りませんと
次の家に行ったらまた同じ答え
そこで夜になるまでマスタードを探したんです
で見つからない もう全部家は終わりました
それで諦めちゃった 諦めて
あ 私の子が死んだんだと
みんな死ぬんだと しょうがないと行って
自分であの遺体をお墓に持って墓場に持っていって
それで仏様のところに来て
よく目が覚めましたと
で 現実に目が覚めたんです
もう私はまあもうこんなひどい目に遭ったのはね
この現実離れの世界でいたんだから
これは家に戻れませんと
出家しますということで
彼女は出家して修行して悟るんです
だからそのストーリーでも
この問題にぶつからないんですね
死ということは認めないんですよ
だから彼女に悟ることできたのは
問題見たんだから 無常を認めたんだからなんです
そこで世の中でも大体死ぬという言葉を使いませんね
亡くなりましたと 亡くなりましたんじゃなくて
遺体はあるんだけどね
やっぱり死んだという言葉は
なんとなく自分のね 親戚
親父として あるいはおじいさん
おばあさんとして ばあさん死んじゃったって
なんか言いにくいところはあるんですよ
なぜかというと やっぱりどこかで死を認めたくないと
なんで世の中にこの天国の話あるんですか？死を認めたくないんだから
ちょっとごまかしてごまかしてやろうと
死んでも天国にいるんだと
そういう言葉 この現代 21世紀になりかかっているこの時代でも
どんな世界でも平気で使っているんです
神様に呼ばれたんだと
認めたくないんですよ
事実を 本当は死んだことは悲しくて
自分にとっては悲しくて認めたくない事実ですね
それでまあしょうがないんだから
じゃあ神様に呼ばれたと
神様のところに行ったと
天国に行きましたと だからありがたいんだと
悲しむなと と言っちゃうんですね
だったら私が言うのは
そんなにありがたいんだったら
神様のところに行くのは早く行けと
みんなで なんでここでうろうろ苦労ばっかりしながら
喧嘩ばっかりしながら
いるんですかと だから
そういうふうに 事実から
現実からずれる ずれる
ずれると離れる 離れるという生き方ばっかりで
だから人類にはいつでもトラブルばっかりなんです
お釈迦様はある日こう言うんです
自分が死ぬんだと知っているならば
人は喧嘩しない 戦争しないんだと
それもものすごい妄想で空想なんですね
戦争も  皆様にも見覚えあるでしょう
あまりにもひどい屁理屈な空想を作って戦争する
最終的にはひどい目に遭うと
命は儚いものだと ちょっと階段で足を滑っても死んじゃうんだよと
とわかったら そんなバカなことをしないでしょう
すぐ消えてしまう この命をね
なんとかなんとかなんとか
まあするようになるでしょうに
命を大事にするようになるでしょうに
でも自分が安全な状況にいて
どれぐらい人を殺せるかと
そればっかり考えるんですね
安全な状態に誰もいないんです
すべて瞬時に消えるんです
私はこの階段の例を出したのは
ある日 ちょっと私のもうすごく疲れて
もう足もすごく痛くて
しっかり歩けないぐらい
ちょっとガタガタ状態に歩いていたんです
歩いているんだけど 自分がいつでもすごい早く歩くんですね
そこで地下鉄のあるところにすごいちょっと高い階段なんですけど
そのまま早く早く降りようと思ったところで
足がすごい不安定で すぐ手すりをつかまったんだけど
その瞬間で思ったのは
あ こんな調子だったら転がっちゃうんだと
この階段だったら必ず死ぬんだと
だから早く歩こうという身を置いておいて
もう体がもうそういう調子だから
気をつけて歩かないとみんなに迷惑だと
ここで死んでしまっちゃったら
その瞬間で次の先のことを思い出しちゃうんです
もしここで倒れて死んじゃったら
もう変な人だからみんな大変
どうするでしょうかと
やっぱり気をつけた方がいいということで気を付けて
電車に乗りましたけどね
だからやっぱりそれは自分の実感なんです
階段見たところで あ これで死んじゃうんだと
だから死ななかったんです
もし俺なんか死ぬわけないんだと思っちゃったら
もうとっくにないんです
こちらは 安心したならば
ですから この安心したがるこの気持ちは全く無知の気持ちであって
何一つも安心するところはないと
すべては無常で変化していくんだと
それは理解しておくと
我々は周りの環境 状況
いつでも計算しながら生活する
そうするといつでも頭が冴えたまんまであるんです
何を見ても すぐそれから何か学ぶ
だから現代の人々のことやらね
やっていることを私は言うんだからって
私は一生懸命冊子を調べたり
あーだこうだそんな研究はしてないんです
全然 ただ電車に乗っただけで
ちょっといろいろ看板それちょっと読んだだけで
そこらへん座ってる人がちょっと見ただけで
そこで あ そういうことかと
今の女の子たちは化粧するのは電車でありますよとかね
一回二回見たら まあそれは今もう流行りやと
すぐわかるんです 今は靴履くんじゃなくて
靴に乗るんだと もっと激しく言えば
ほんのちょっと ポケット携帯用の梯子も必要になるでしょうと
それは冗談で思っちゃう
本当に思っちゃうんです
冗談でても この状況がもっと激しくなっちゃうと
やっぱり携帯用の梯子を必要になるんだと
靴に乗るために それでまたこの体も弱いし
女の子はみんなご飯食べないんだからね
その上 このものすごい
このもう竹馬に乗ったようなね
靴に乗っていくと この腰の動き方
足の運び方を見ると これ結構健康に悪いだろうと
この人たちはこれからいろんな体の現象を起こしだしそうと
それでこういう女の子は子供を産めるだろうかと
そこまで余計な心配までしちゃうと
もっと体を大事にしろと
あんた方は自分だけの体じゃないんだと
男とは違うんだと 人類を作るのはあなた方ではないかと
だから親にまで気持ちを入れて
もうちょっと 女の子っていうのはもっと大事に育てなくちゃいけないんだと
そういう道徳をなぜ教えられてないんですかと
ただ単におしゃれでかっこよく生きるだけはノーじゃないんだと
女の人の幸せというよりは
義務感というか責任感というかね
男よりもすごい大事な命なんです
すごく気をつけなくてはいけないんです
だから 女で生まれたってことはもう大変なことだよと
冗談はよしなさいと もっと責任感持てと
人類に対して あなたにはやってあげなくちゃ
大変大事な仕事はあるんだと
それは男にはできるものじゃないんだという
この女性としての責任感というものはね
叩き込まれてないんだとかね
そこまでもう瞬時に思い浮かんだりするんで
その辺も全部余計なんですけど
とにかくほんのちょっとこと目に入ったら
そこからいろんなことを勉強できるんです
だからそうすると まあできるだけ我々に時代遅れにならないで
生活することはできるんです
ですから この無常観というのは
過去を見て後ろを向いて
進むことじゃないんです
世の中みんな言ってるのは
後ろを向いて進んでくださいと
後ろ向きで進むと後ろに進まなくちゃいけないでしょうに
だから倒れちゃうんです
だからこの地球上でずっと問題ばっかしで
後ろを見ているんだから
我々が言うのは後ろを向くなと
前見なさいと 前見ると周りも見えるんです
歩いたっても倒れません
だから後ろを向いて経済活動したんだから
バブルという大きな穴に落ちてしまったんです
これが穴 小さな穴じゃないんですよ
すごい穴なんですね これ
壁はすべすべで登れないんです
ですから この無常の教えで
お釈迦様は我々に何を希望したかというと
この瞬時にひらめく智慧
できることがあったら
すぐそこを解決できる智慧なんです
それでこの計画立てないんではないかと
すべて無常だからという疑問もあります
計画は一応将来性を見て作るんではないかと
我々は まあ簡単な答え
まあ計画は立てられますけど
でも人間の計画っていうのは
あのいちばん最初のストーリーで言ったような計画なんですね
だから実行するのは大変なんです
あの妄想 空想から出来上がった計画なんです
この空想の思考から 空想から作る計画はもう捨てた方がいいんです
どうしても空想ばっかりしているんだったら
何の計画もなし 今日だけの人生だと思った方が安心かもしれません
安全かもしれません 安心ではなくて
明日もわかりませんと
明日は明日になったら頑張ってみるんだと
だからこの具体的な計画っていうのは
現在から作るもんなんです
だから現在の状況は明確に判断しておくと理解しておくと
あ それだったらこの通りになれるでしょうと
こうすれば良いでしょうと
ですから 持っているものをちゃんとこの
アカウントしないで立てる計画は良くないんです
何か将来に対して計画を立てると
やっぱりいつでも 自分がどれぐらい能力を持っているかと
どれぐらいそれに余裕があるんですか？とか
社会状況はどういうことですかとかね
そういうことを計算すると
いとも簡単に じゃあ次のステップは見えてくるんです
だから 仏教のから言える計画性っていうのはそういうものなんです
ただ単に世界支配しようとか
ただ空想で じゃあ億万長者になってやるぞとかね
あの幼稚園の子供たちみたいに生き方は良くないんです
幼稚園の子供たちの将来何になりたいかというと
ほとんど決まっていて
女の子だったらね あの幼稚園の先生になりたいとかね
病院に行った経験があるんだったら
看護師になりたいとかね
男の子だったら電車の運転士になりたいとか
決まってるんだけど 将来は
でもみんな日本の男の子
みんな電車の運転士になってみる
これ困ったもんですけど
女の子たちはみんなこの看護師になったり
幼稚園の先生になったりしちゃうと
これまた困ったもんですけどね
でもある程度で その子供たちもそれほどへんてこりんじゃないんです
自分が経験している世界で
自分がこれからチャレンジするべきものを決めるんですよ
だから その子供は電車の電車の運転士になりたいという子は
それ経験しているんですよ
すごい大きな でっかい
力強い あれ 子供は小さいんだから
電車っていうのはものすごい大化け物で見えるんです
それでそれ一人の人間が運転するんだから
これ想像を絶する世界なんですよ
だからもう運転士になりたいと思っちゃうんです
でもその子は空想しているとは言い切れないんですよ
自分がそれ経験しているんです
あ 私はチャレンジするんだったら
これにチャレンジするんだと
幼稚園に入った女の子にしても
その幼稚園で面倒見ている人々が一生懸命子供たちを管理して
ああしなさい こうしなさいと
はい 並んでくださいとかね
みんな自由自在に操っているんだから
やっぱり支配力っていうのはすごい女性にあるんだからね
だからまあ そうなりたいと
大人になるともっと変になっちゃうんですね
だから計画を立てる場合は
いつでも私はどれぐらいものを持っているんですかと
それはどのようにこの環境の中で動かせばいいんですかと
やっぱり時空関係の中で立てるもんなんです
それでまあ 聖 とかね  5年計画
10年計画とかいろいろ立てますけど
ほとんどうまくいかないんですね
日本よりもね 他の国々のあの経済活動を見てると
やっぱりまあファイブイヤープランとかね
スリーイヤープランとかいろいろプラン作っちゃうんです
計画 で 大体うまくいかないんですね
なぜかというと 政治家だから
この人気を買うこと 人々を抑えること
そこら辺だけ考えて空想的な計画を立てちゃうんですね
この空想的な計画はもう大変不幸なもとでダメになっちゃう
ですから 計画に際も やっぱり現状というか
この今の状況はよく理解して計算して比べた上で
比べていく途中で自動的になってくるんです
計画っていうのは そうすると失敗しない社会
失敗しない政治 失敗しない生き方が生まれてくるんです
そこで無常でもう一つ助けてくれることがあります
計画を立ててもうまくいかない時はありますよ
条件変わる時もありますよと
計画を立てても何か条件変わることあるでしょ？あると私は聞くと
あなたに計画変更できますかと
順次はい 計画変更と こういうことになったんだから
こうではなくて こういうふうな計画でいくんだと
それは一番必要なんです
決めたんだから 決めたんだからって言ってやるんじゃないんです
勝手に決めたんだからと言ったっても
世界の状況はそれに合わせてくれない時もありますから
ですから 計画を立てるのは一向に構わない
でも 計画自体が自動的に成り立せるように
現状状況を明確に把握することは必要なんです
そうすると 計画っていうのは自動的に成り立っちゃうんです
自動的に成り立った計画はだいたいこういう答えなの
こういう答えしかないんだと
こうするしか方法はないんだという
かなり確実なものなんです
選択ないことになっちゃうんです
それでまた状況判断をいつでもしているんだから
ちょっとでも条件が変われば
それだったらこういう風にするんだと
その心の余裕と柔軟性なんですね
必要なのは それは無常から出てくるもの
そういうわけで 仏教ではいつでも現在を見ろと
現在に頭を絞っておこうと
それは事実だと と言っているんです
この将来に縛られる人についても
また大変将来ではなくて
将来のことを一人言いましたけど
過去についても縛られている人々に対して
ストーリーがありまして
これもこの前も言った同じストーリーなんですね
すみません 勉強足らなくて
新しいストーリーは思い浮かばないんです
これは経典で出てくるストーリーなんです
ですから 当然作ったストーリーです
実際にあったストーリーではなくて
ある若い二人が村で会いて
人財産作ろうと思う 村を出ようと
で 村を出る 村を出ると歩くと
このあの人の便ですか
このそういうものをもうすごくこの外でみんなそういう便所して
もう溜まって硬くなっている
別に臭いことなんでもない
ほとんど肥料になりかかっているもので
あ これは肥料に 我々はこれを拾って肥料に
誰かにあげれば 肥料としていくらか儲かるんだと
それいい考え方なんですね
そこで二人とも大きな袋を作って
その袋に全部入れて もう頭の上に乗せて持っていくんです
まあ別に臭いわけでもなんでもないんだと
それ持っていくと いくらか行ったところで麻見つかるんですね
麻っていったって植物だからいっぱいあって
そしたら一人があ これよりは麻の方がお金になるんだと
言ったら もう一人の人はあんた何をね
どこまで苦労して この人に人里に来るまでね
これ運んできたと思いますかと
捨てると言うんですか？私は捨てません
あんた捨てなさいと言ったら
一人の人があれ捨てて
あの袋 麻をいっぱい切って束にして
大きな束を作って 私はこれを売るんだと
言ったところで まあもう行ったところで
麻でも腐ってくると この線が出てきますからね
それで布を織ったりしますね
そういう腐ってる線になってる糸を見つかるんですね
その人はやっぱりあんたはね
この袋を捨てなさいよと
この麻そのもの 麻の植物そのものよりも
この糸を拾ってきて売っちゃえば
もっと金になるんだと
でも一人はそれを断る
あの人は麻を捨てて麻の糸を持っていく
どんどんその人が麻で織った布を見つかる
一人が一人がまだあの古いものばっかり持っていく
そこまで持っていたんだから捨てませんと
大変感謝深い人でしょうね
そこで番目の人が次に綿を見つかる
そこであれ捨てて 綿の方がもっと価値があるんだと
それから布を見つかる
あれ捨てて布になる どんどん絹にまでなる
そこで高価な布のなんかそれ全部捨てて
絹を持っていくと で そこを行くところで
やっぱりもう宝物に出会う
金とか であったら その人はこんな高価なもう絹とかね
絹とかそんなものよりは
金でもほんのちょっと持って行ったってもね
すごい金になるんだと
言ったら この人の弁を運んでる人に
あんたね 今でもいいんだから捨てなさいよと
そしたらもうこの人断るんですね
そこまで苦労して この重いものを持ってきて
平気で捨てることを言うんですかと
なんて失礼なことかと
あんたなんかいつでも新しいものばっかりいくんだから勝手にしなさいよと
ただ その人なんのこの人
言うこと聞かないんだと言って
絹なんか全部捨てて 金とか銀とか
そういう宝物を袋にして
それ持っていって やがて自分の村に戻ると
戻ったら金と銀と宝石とかの袋に持ってきた人はすごい金持ちになって豊かになって
村人に褒められて あの人はけなされたんだと
そういうストーリーで
何をお釈迦様は言いた
これはもう経典に出てくるんだから
我々に言いたがっていることは見えるでしょうね
古いものにつかまるなっていうことなんです
意味のあるものにどんどん心を変えて
変えて 変えて 変えていかなくちゃならないんだと
ですから この無常論っていうのは
そういうふうな かなり複雑で難しいかもしれませんだけど
大体そのような教えなんです
だから無常 信じる人が無常を認める人が
無常の中で生きている人はいつでも先進的なんです
現代的なんです 落ちこぼれにはなりません
追い越されません このレースで
この競争でいつでも先端にいるんです
それは望むところでしょうに
誰でもどんな人間でも言わなくたっても先端にいたいんだと
そんな大変なことじゃないんですよ
人生には遅いということはないんです
なぜ遅いと思いますかというと
もう過去に縛られるんだからなんです
例えば このニュースなんかに
たまに外国のニュースなんかにも出ることなんです
例えば  80歳のばあちゃんがもうまた新しい恋をして結婚したんだとかね
ニュースになっちゃうんですね
なんでニュースになるかというと
これ大変なことやと思うんだからなんです
私は別にニュースになるものじゃないんだと
そのおばあちゃんが誰がめたところで
もう恋をしたならば じゃあ結婚しようやと
結構元気じゃないかなと
だからそこは応援してるわけではなくて
まあ私にすれば 今更あんた結婚じゃなくてもっとチャレンジするものはいっぱいあるでしょうと
また誰かの旦那のお世話をするとかね
大変やと だから別に不思議でも何でもないんです
やりたければやってもいいんだけど
まあ僕は我々はもうチャレンジしたいものはいっぱいあるんだから
他のことにチャレンジしたっても
それは一向に構いません
70歳  80歳になって
また大学に入り直して
また勉強したっても それは全然
一向に構いません で でもそういうのをうまく生きるのは
この無常をしっかり理解している人なんですよ
我々はまた 例えば女の人は子供は自由になったところで
また大学に入り直して
新しいものを勉強しようとしたいと思うでしょうね
その時も失った過去を取り戻そうという気持ちがあるんですね
あれは危ないんです 失ったものを取り戻してもらおうと
あれは無常を認めていないことなんです
いつでもやっぱり先を見てやった方がいいんです
年取ってからフランス語でも勉強したってもいいんだけど
やっぱりこの失った過去を取り戻すためではなくて
今役に立つか立たないかと
それだったらもう 60
50  70歳になったっても
また フランス語でも勉強したっても構いません
私も何回も考えたんで
またもう一回 いろいろ忘れた言語とかね
いっぱいありますからね
また勉強し直そうかなと思ったところで
やっぱり言語を勉強すると
このガキの頃の精神状態に戻らなくちゃいけないんですよ
これは体ですとかね 私はスマナサーラですとかね
あの精神状態はもう戻りたくないんですね
まあだったらいいやとやめるんだと
でも この子供頃の精神状態に戻るわけではなくて
まあそれは使えるんだと
もし私は日本ではなくて他の国に行ったら
すぐその国のことを勉強しますよ
それはもうガキの頃に戻るためではなくて
その現在状況に必要になるんだからなんです
で  1ヶ月半ぐらいではなくて
もっと短かったんだけど
タイにいたんだけど その時はもう片っ端からタイの言葉を勉強する
カセットやら英語ではなかなかないんですからね
もう全部拾ったんです
拾ったって あちこちで調べて調べて買ったんですね
なぜかというと もうそちらの人々
いろんな人々がこの喋りたくて
いろんなことをわかるんだけど
全く向こうは英語がわからないし
こちらタイ語わからないし
やっぱりコミュニケーションできないんだと
いつでも誰かと一緒に行かないと
ということで まあ買ったことは買ったんだけど
まだ二度と向こうへ行くことはできなかったし
まあそれでまあそのままもうゴミになったんですけど
そういうことで この年取ってから勉強したっても構いませんし
新しいものをチャレンジしたっても構いませんし
でもいっそでもこの過去に戻るためっていうことだけは忘れて
今現在の状況に必要だからやってるんだと
今私に必要ですから やってるんだと
今の私に そういうことだったら
何にチャレンジしたっても一向に構いません
あ それからこの一つのポイントで終了します
この かなり将来のために計画という
例えばお金の貯金するとかね
やっぱりその場合は経典にあるんで
はっきりと お金全部使うなと
収入は このシガーラという若者にお釈迦様が教えた教えがあります
それ中部経 長部経典に出てくるんだけど
その人に言っているのは
もう本当はもう 50%
仕事に使って 収入はね
まあ商売だから 1 割じゃなくて 25%貯金しなさいと
だから使えるのは 25%なんだよ
収入の 今の我々の収入から見れば
これは無理ですけどね
だからやっぱり商売やってる人をね
まあそうやって自由商売やってる人にとってはね
かなり収入あるんだからね
難しいわけでもないんです
だからお釈迦様は投資するために 50%だと
貯金は 25%だと言ってるんだから
なんか割り当てが多すぎですよ
現代経済学から見れば
でも その割り当てでなくてもお分かりになるんですよ
お釈迦様は経済に 財布の経済状況はどのように見ているんですかと
いつでも収入増えるようなことを考えなくてはならないんです
だから 自分の仕事に必要であるならば
高いお金を払って何か機械買ったり
コンピューター買ったりしたっても
それは構いません 借金は仏教はすごく嫌われるんだけど
嫌われるんだけど ちゃんと収入が得るんだと
商売になるんだというならば
きちんとした計画があるならば
借金してでも何か新しい機械買ったりとかね
するのはいいんだけど
今我々のやり方がちょっと計算がやりすぎ 2
3000万円借金して何か機械やら買ってるんだけど
その買ったところでちゃんと 5年
6 年間安定して商売できるかというところまで考えません
なんとかなるんではないか
そのなんとかなるんではないかというとこは変なんですね
そんな信仰は それでやられてもう仕事うまくいかなかったら借金だけ残っちゃうんですね
そういう危険もありますよ
計画性ない人にとっては
日本でもよく見られるんですね
そういうことは  ある人がテレビで見たんだけど
この 今 冷蔵庫に使うガス
今使っていけないと言っているガスは何でしたっけ？え？フロンガス
フロンガス使ってはいけないと最近言っていて
あるこのロンダリやってる人がその情報もどんどん世界で言い始めていたんです
日本で知られるのは遅かったんだけど
オゾンホールの問題とかね
もうかなり前から言っていたんです
それで日本でもフロンガスは良くないという話が広げてあって
そこで日本の政府も何かコントロールしなくちゃいけないという状態になっているにも関わらず
ロンドンのドライクリーニングのために万円かななんとかのすごい機械を買ってしまったんです
ローンで その機械はフロンガス使うんです
その人文句言うんですよ
私は年間年間仕事しないとローンが払えないんだと
そんな決まり作ったっても困るんだと
私は考えたのは なんという失礼な人かと
あなた一人でもうローン払えないで
もうホームレスになったっても構いませんよと
それまで頭が悪ければ
なぜならば それぐらいするならば
それぐらいの状況判断しておいた方がよかったでしょうに
それだったら今日本で機械なくても注文してでもフロンガス使わないでドライクリーニングできる機械で作ってくださいと言った方が長持ちするでしょうに
だから ああいうのはあまりにもこのあまりにもひどい非合理的な投資なんですね
だから やっぱり無常を知った方がいいんですよ
無常を知った人が投資すると
ちゃんと投資したお金が倍になって
倍になって 倍 倍になって返ってくるかということは計算してからやるんです
国へ帰ったら いろんな若者たちが私にお金をちょっとくれませんか？とか言ったりする場合あるんです
ちょっとじゃなくて かなり額を要求する場合もあります
私はもう若者に言われたらだいたいあげたいという気持ちにはまずなるんです
自分にはそれほど役に立たないんだから
ほとんどみんなに配る性格ですからね
美味しいご飯でもらったら
誰か配る人はないかと調べる
自分ではあまり食べようと思わないんです
それは置いておいて 私はまず徹底的に質問するんです
何を質問するんですかと
相手に計画性あるかないか
ただ単にくれるんだからもらっちゃうぞという気持ちで言ってるんですかないかと
私は知ってるんだから得したんだと
そういう特権でもらおうとしているかないかと
だからそこを質問すると
出てくる答えから判断すると
あ この子には計画性がある
具体的だ 現実主義だとわかったら
関係ある人にあげないで
全く関係ない人にでもあげたりはします
もう一回きりで またもう顔を合わせることもないかもしれません
それでもじゃあいいですよ
持って行ってくださいとあげます
なぜかというと しっかり調べるんですよ
現実主義かと 現実主義だったら
まあその人はそれで確実に幸せになるんですね
そうでないと 自分の親戚だとかね
信者さんの知ってる人やとか
そんなことでは特権で取ろうとする
そういう人はダメになっちゃうんですね
ですから この投資するべきなんですけど
ちゃんと現実主義で状況判断して
この商売はもう何年間続けてできるかという研究をしないと
固い頭でできるわけじゃないんです
過去に縛られたできるわけじゃないんです
あのロンダリアの人も同じでしょうに
過去に縛られ 自分がずっとロンダリーをやっていたんだから
家は だからある機械は古くなって
じゃあ新しい機械入れてもう商売するんだと
単なる過去に縛られただけなんですね
だからおそらくあれはまあ
商売停止命令出るのわかりませんだけど
それからは出るようなことになるでしょう
あんな大量にフロンガスね
空気に出すということは
日本の政府も認めるわけじゃいきませんから
ですから いつでもそうやって
このゴミの問題にしてもね
大躍進とかなんとかとかね
最初からチェックして
じわじわと新しい方向に行くようにしておかないと
お手上げ状態になっちゃうんですね
同じパターンで繰り返していこうと思ったら
社会問題だ 環境問題だとか泣いたりする
そういう問題 みんなこの無常を認めてないんだから
現状を見てないんだだから
そこで科学者でも誰かでも何か早く研究して言っちゃうと反対するんですね
そんなことはないんだ
例えば 携帯電話の電波が脳にトラブルを起こすではないかと
脳細胞を破壊するんではないかという意見はあるんです
それで電話会社やら基準を作ったのはイギリスですけど
その博士の研究で 科学者でも絶対ないんだと平気で言うんですね
でもどこかで他の学者たちがこすこすと研究してたところで
この電波が入っちゃうと
細胞には異変が起こるんだと
これは人間人体実験やったわけじゃなくて
すごい柔らかい なんとかミミズみたいな何か虫をとってきて
この虫の生活している環境にこの電波を流して
そしたらやっぱり解剖するところで細胞に変化あるんだと
いて そこを発表すると
アメリカでイギリスでもそれに反対意見は出てくる
認めません 認めません
科学的じゃない 科学的じゃないと認めませんというんだけど
その携帯電話 そこでアメリカのいくつかの会社がもうとっくに開発しているんです
電波防止の器具を 携帯電話につけるいろんなもの
でも紹介していない もしやがて世界でみんなトラブルを起こしたり
脳細胞が壊れたりとかね
おかしくなってひどい目になったところで
他の会社もやっぱりどうしようかと考える時に
あの会社がサッと全部店に出して
もう特許を取ってるんだから
売って儲かるでしょうに
ですから ずるいかもしれませんんだけど
科学者のやり方も悪いものははっきりと悪いと言った方がいいんだけど
商売の関係で言わない
言ったってもそれを抑える
抑えるんだけど やっぱり状況判断している人々が
携帯電話を作っている会社が前もって
もう作っているんだと
だからそれは本当にいい商売だと私は思いますよ
いい商売と言ったっても
この倒れない とにかく生き延びる商売なんですね
そういうことで この計画性っていうのはそういうことで
投資する場合も いつでも無常であることを変化するんだということも計算した上でやるものなんですね
そこでなぜ貯金するんですかと
なぜお釈迦様は貯金認めたんですかと
それは本当のとこは 皆様思っているように
老後の安全のためじゃないんです
その貯金のとこを言っているところで
経典で書いているのは
予想しないものは人に起こるんだと
予想しないものが起きたら
それにお金がかかるんだと
だから借金しないで その問題かお金必要な問題だったら解決できるんだと
ただ単にね 将来の老後のため
老後のためと老後のために貯金する人はお金使わないんですね
老人になるの何歳からかとわかってないんだから
この年から老人だから
じゃあ貯金で使おうということになりませんだからね
だから何かあったら借金しませんと
何かあったらということで
外国旅行するときでもぴったしと計算して
例えば 13万5400円で大丈夫だよと思って
それぐらい持っていく人がいるんですかね
13万5千 じゃあやっぱり 20万
やっぱり 25万円ぐらい持っていくということになるでしょうに
あれ 全部使うんじゃないんです
予想しないことが起きたらと
私もいつでもそういうことなんです
予想できないことが起きたら
いつでもすぐ行動できるように準備しているんです
そういうことで この仏教の無常論というのは
このように在家の世界では使用するものなんです
で 在家であろうが出家であろうが
お釈迦様は一つだけ厳密に求めてほしいものがありまして
智慧の開発 無常を認めない人には智慧がないんです
無常を認めるともう安心できませんだから
24時間勉強しなくちゃいけないんです
24時間物に気づいていなくちゃいけないんです
そうすると いつでも問題が起きたらすぐ答えが出せるような人間にはなるんです
それは普通に我々に幸せに生きている
生きていられるための方法だと思います
それは決して無常なしには成り立ちません
永遠な魂あるんだと ああだこうだ話がなると成り立たないんです
人間 人間みんな亡くなったら阿弥陀様に呼ばれるんだと
神様に呼ばれるんだと思ったら
それで成長はストップするんです
わかりませんだと 地獄に落ちるか
天国に行くか わかったもんじゃないんだと思った人が
自分の人生を正すんですよ
ああいうのは怠け教えなんです
仏教は怠け嫌いです お釈迦様は仏教というよりも
そうやって常に努力することを目指しているんです
話は以上ですが 無常というのは人間にほとんどトラブルなし
無き幸福でしっかりと生きるためである
それから 毎日毎日 我々の智慧を開発
智慧が開発して 立派な人間になるための教えであると理解していただければ大変ありがたいと思います
どうもありがとうございました